[Musique]
une attestation plein d'asterisk quatre
rayons de déplacement différents et un
encadré très technique
hier les français avaient du mal avec la
nouvelle attestation rien compris
qu'elle complexité franchement castex
égale complexe car on avait du mal à y
croire c'est presque drôle tonnes donc
des confiné des confiné qui avant
l'autorisation de circuler sans exagérer
et nous sommes invités à nous confiner
tout en respirant dehors bon ça me
paraît d'une clarté est tout à fait
grande elle m'a dit que j'allais sentir
le moment de l'injection mais rien du
tout c'était très bien entre est rapide
il savait ce que je vais vous dire je ne
peux que recommander vivement ce vaccin
si on est au confinement aujourd'hui
pourquoi ce nouveau confinement qui n'en
est pas un tout en étant un qui est
incompréhensible d'ailleurs c'est
pourquoi c'est parce qu'on n'a pas pris
les mesures en amont qu'on peut prendre
encore tout réussit au premier ministre
sur le plan de la vaccination
plus de 26 millions de première dose un
adulte sur deux et 711 me l'injection
pour la seule journée d'hier un nouveau
record face au tollé
gérald darmanin passe des consignes
d'indulgence contrôle très pédagogique
et beaucoup de compréhension avant de
verbaliser en dernier ressort
un message compréhensif mais aussi une
façon pour le ministre de dire qu'avec
une attestation pareil pas étonnant que
certains soit déboussolé une épidémie ça
ne se gère pas comme on gérait une crise
liée au terrorisme ou une guerre une
épidémie se gère au contraire en donnant
beaucoup d'informations je me refuse à
parler de confinement tout simplement
parce que ce n'en est pas un un autre
phrase du jour est signée olivier
ferrand dans le parisien donc ce n'est
pas un confinement
le président de la république l'a dit
vous le répéter cependant les français
qui nous écoutent quand on leur dit vous
pouvez sortir de chez vous sans limite
ils seront près que celle de respecter
les gestes maria ils comprennent de
comparer non seulement ils ont vécu ce
que c'était les comprennent fonds ont
fait confiance on responsabilise les
gens plutôt que d'être dans une logique
un petit peu de
deux gendarmes et tout le monde ce qui
ne fait plaisir à personne je crois et
on le sent vraiment dans le monde du
travail
1re confinement très dur y compris le
week-end avec beaucoup d'interdiction de
sortie aura été très très dur à avaler
d'une certaine manière pour nombre de
citoyens il ya une grosse latitude la
latitude monsieur véran dit que je jette
du venin non je fais attention au
contraire je pèse mes mots depuis le
début pour pas ajouter de la pagaille à
la pagaille mais votre site avec
mélenchon et que tout le monde comprenne
dans le parisien olivero ici le
populisme pouvait sauver des vies on le
saurait les français n'ont pas besoin du
venin de jean luc mélenchon ils veulent
voir soins et des vaccins je demande à
tous les maires de france solennellement
de faire ouvrir tous les commerces de
proximité qui respecte les règles
sanitaires
parce que cela la désobéissance mais
c'est du débat parce que y'en a assez
d'être gouvernés par des incapables vous
ne pouvez pas inviter chez vous des
personnes pour un dîner aujourd'hui
encore une fois la logique c'est chacun
chez soi ou alors dehors parce que zéro
donc à plus de régler si c'est légal
l'âge et la logique aujourd'hui c'est à
dire de ne pas recevoir chez vous des
personnes qui ne sont pas de votre
domicile
ça s'est passé vendredi on l'a appris
sur le compte twitter de la ministre de
la culture roselyne bachelot je vous
propose de regarder qui remet une
décoration les insignes de commandeur de
la légion d'honneur à michel sardou un
artiste aux multiples facettes je la
cite agnès pannier runes h et k contact
dans le gouvernement voilà qu'il a il a
tombé le masque
elisabeth bornent toujours à l'
isolement cédric haut sur le drian
également d'un cluster gouvernement
roselyne bachelot annonce sur twitter
être positive au coronavirus à la suite
vous le voyez de symptômes respiratoires
elle ne manquera pas de donner des
nouvelles régulièrement payés à défaut
de précaution non non non je vous dire
tous les membres du gouvernement ont
fait particulièrement attention d'abord
pour des raisons sanitaires et ensuite
parce que
doit être exemplaire